bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant la séance de questions
cribles alors les questions cribles vous
le savez ce sont ces questions très
précises que posent les sénateurs un
ministre le thème
aujourd'hui la pratique et la réalité
agricole et le code de la propriété
intellectuelle et le ministre
aujourd'hui c'est stéphane le foll
ministre de l'agriculture un débat
d'actualité alors que la commission
européenne vient tout juste d'autoriser
la culture d'un nouveau maïs ogm pas là
tout de suite on se dirige vers
l'hémicycle a une idée assez simple je
crois que sur cette question des
semences et de tout ce qui peut être
poser comme question avec les questions
de la génétique des organismes
génétiquement modifiés tous les débats
qu'on va avoir
aujourd'hui doivent être mis sous un
objectif simple essayer d'éviter les
caricatures j'inviterais tous ceux qui
vont intervenir après de rester dans ce
cadre là il n'y a pas ce qui serait
étonnant
je ne sais quelles idées rétrogrades sur
la question des semences et ceux qui
parce qu'ils auraient fait des choix un
moment ou un autre serait les tenants du
progrès voilà le premier élément que je
voudrais donner dans ce débat le
deuxième c'est sur la question vous avez
posé il ya deux types de décret celui
qui concerne les semences et vous avez
évoqué effectivement un décret qui sera
pris sur les espèces pouvant bénéficier
des de relation les semences de ferme
il étendra la liste des vingt-et-une
actuelle à 13 nouvelles espèces en
particulier les sojas les trèfles élu
par les poids et pour ce qui est de la
question liée à l'autre décret qui n'est
pas obligatoire qu'il n'y a pas
d'obligation de prendre sur les
questions liées à la reconnaissance et
sur les organisations liées à la
recherche et au financement
ce décret nécessite d'abord qu'on
s'appuie sur des accords
interprofessionnels n'a pas d'obligation
donc on va attendre qui est là des
discussions qui permettent d'avancer
avant de s'engager sur un décret plus
précis voilà ce que je voulais vous
répondre sur la question qui était posée
sur les questions liées au décret y en a
un qui va être publiée rapidement qui
étendra le nombre des espèces je les dis
et l'autre nous privilégions d'abord ce
qui est la règle
les accords interprofessionnels merci
mon cher collègue si vous voulez réagir
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre de cette réponse
mais ce qui intéresse le monde agricole
naturellement c'est le deuxième point
que j'évoquais c'est la rémunération des
sélectionneurs donc c'est là-dessus
qu'il faut une réflexion et qu'il faut
avancer pour répondre au monde agricole
et faire attention à la concurrence des
grandes puissances étrangères qui sont
très dangereuses pour notre économie
c'est bien la parole à présent aymeri de
montesquiou pour le groupe udc
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président je le ministre jarre collègues
chacun le sait la france est le premier
producteur européen de semences est le
deuxième exportateur mondial
notre pays a une position particulière
sur la profitabilité du vivant en effet
pour les semences
le système actuel de certificat
d'obtention végétale convient à tous les
acteurs aux agriculteurs comme aux
semenciers grâce à la législation de
2011 et pourtant
pour ce qui est les ogm le dogmatisme
l'emportent la culture on est presque
totalement interdite mais on importe et
on consomme par exemple du soja
transgénique
où est la cohérence cette schizophrénie
est totalement hypocrite
les grandes entreprises semencières
françaises ont dû délocaliser leurs
recherches à l'étranger surtout aux
états unis
nos principaux concurrents cela induit
une perte de savoir-faire d'emploi et un
risque d'exclusion des marchés de
semences la recherche agricole et
agroalimentaire
deux voies est une priorité notamment à
travers l'inra laboratoires d'excellence
qui nous ouvre les applications
pratiques d'une recherche éthique et
encadré faut-il laisser les brevets sur
les végétaux aux multinationales
américaines
comment pourrez-vous nous défendre dans
les négociations sur l'accord
transatlantique des enjeux sont
évidemment considérable il s'agit de
l'avenir alimentaire de la planète ne
prennez ne vous pas le risque de nous
couper des marchés internationaux par
dogmatisme
comment monsieur le ministre comptez
vous a demandé votre projet de loi
d'avenir de l'agriculture prochainement
examiné par notre assemblée pour que
celui-ci ne coupe pas de la recherche de
l'innovation et de la prospective
merci monsieur stéphane le foll ce
présent monsieur le sénateur j'avais
commencé mon propos justement en
essayant de vous dire qu'il faudrait
éviter les caricatures
eh bien monsieur le sénateur votre
question prouve que nous avons encore
des progrès communs et collectifs à
faire si ce que vous dites était vrai la
france serait elle aujourd'hui le
premier producteur de semences d'europe
la france serait elle aujourd'hui le
troisième producteur de semences du
monde
la france serait-elle aujourd'hui le
premier exportateur de semences du monde
il faut quand même qu'on objective un
peu ce débat il faut qu'on essaye de
regarder les choses avec pragmatisme
réalité est ce que la grande question
posée par les fameuses organismes
génétiquement modifiés
souvent vantée par certains c'est
l'enjeu du marché mondial de la semence
si c'était le cas on serait pas là où
nous en sommes et nous avons gardé cette
place sans avoir d'ailleurs de grandes
firmes internationales dont on entend
souvent parler qui viennent d'ailleurs
d'outre-atlantique
mais en ayant plutôt un tissu de pme pmi
qui fonctionne parfaitement bien et qui
répondent à des objectifs extrêmement
précis je répète nous sommes aujourd'hui
devenu cette année le premier
exportateur mondial où l'an dernier plus
tôt
le premier exportateur mondial donc
qu'est ce qu'on a à faire pas à se poser
les questions du passé a essayé d'ouvrir
les grands débats de l'avenir a essayé
de penser les choses n'ont pas avec ce
qui s'est passé mais en essayant de se
projeter sur l'avenir
faisons en sorte de savoir à quoi on
doit répondre quel est l'enjeu
à l'échelle mondiale il est celui du
défi alimentaire tout le monde sera
d'accord
il est celui de la prise en compte de la
préservation des ressources naturelles
et la capacité qu'on a à produire des
produits agricoles on sera d'accord
à partir de là est ce que la question de
savoir si des ogm résistant à tel ou tel
herbicides c'est la réponse
j'en doute d'autant plus que la réalité
me donne plutôt raison qu'est ce qui va
se passer demain et ça je veux le dire
ici au sénat une page va se tourner la
question des ogm de la première
génération va se tourner et la recherche
scientifique a va s'ouvrir avec d'autres
potentialités et je dis ça sans remettre
en cause la potentialité qu'il y a dans
des recherches génétiques mais je dis
que les ogm résistant aux herbicides des
ogm pesticides
je crois qu'on va tourner la page et
qu'il y en a une autre qui va s'ouvrir
je pense en particulier sur les débats
qui ont lieu aujourd'hui sur le riz doré
il ya des questions posées pour
l'amélioration du niveau de vitamine a
dans un certain nombre de céréales
ça c'est une question qui répond à une 1
h jeux d'intérêt général et non pas un
enjeu de profits particulier c'est ça
l'enjeu
la page se tourne si vous êtes capables
ouvrons ensemble une nouvelle page
très bien merci aymeri de montesquiou
je ne sais pas qui fait de la caricature
bouger le ministre
j'ai souhaité qu' on passe par l'inra
pour faire une recherche éthique et
encadré je constate un fait évident
c'est que nous faisons des recherches
sur des produits parce qu'on ne peut pas
les faire en france
je constate aussi que l' on importe des
semences qu'on n'a pas le droit de
produire
donc il nous semble qu'il ya un paradoxe
évident
ni vous ni moi nous sommes des forcenés
d'assystem ou de l'autre je considère
qu'il ya un marché considérable et que
les certains interdits qui touche nos
semences risque de nous couper du marché
international qui est considérable non
nous continuons avec la question de
renée nicoux pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ma question porte sur les
inquiétudes qui ont récemment émaner du
milieu agricole à l'occasion de la
discussion sur la loi de lutte contre la
contrefaçon
au parlement les également dans le cadre
de la loi d'avenir agricole sur le
risque de remise en cause du recours aux
semences de ferme pour les agriculteurs
ces inquiétudes ont pu être légitimement
susciter par le renforcement de la
protection douanière et son extension au
certificat d'obtention végétale prévu
par la loi de lutte contre la
contrefaçon récemment adopté par le
parlement
ainsi le contrôle accru sur les droits
de propriété intellectuelle sur les
variétés végétales a pu s'apparenter à
un dessaisissement pour les agriculteurs
de leurs droits à ressemer sans
autorisation du semencier le produit de
leur récolte obtenue grâce à la mise en
culture de certaines variétés protégées
or l' avantage qui a toujours été mis en
avant du certificat d'obtention végétale
tel qu'il a été conçu dès 1961 et que le
monopole d'exploitation de la variété
qu'il couvre ne vaut que pour
l'exploitation de cette variété et ne
fait pas obstacle à l'utilisation de
celle ci comme source de nouvelles
variétés obtenu par croisement
par ailleurs les prémices des débats
autour de la loi d'avenir pour
l'agriculture et la forêt ont souligné
une attente largement partagée des
agriculteurs pour défendre l'utilisation
de semences de ferme sur leur propre
exploitation
ce qui est autorisé par la loi mais
qu'en est-il de l' échange de semences
dans le cadre de l'entr'aide ou de la
vente dans la mesure où cette
transaction de semences autoproduite
d'une variété protégée par un ceo vais
peut être qualifié de contrefaçon aussi
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
assurer que les semences de ferme sont
toujours protégés par la législation
nationale et que les agriculteurs ne
seront pas susceptibles de se retrouver
accusé du délit de contrefaçon
s'ils utilisent ces semences sur leurs
propres excès
natation hausse ils procèdent à des
échanges dans le cadre de l'entr'aide
monsieur le ministre président madame la
sénatrice sur ce sujet là aussi je
souhaite rappeler la position qui c'est
qui est celle qui guide le ministère
dans ce débat sur le débat sur la
protection liée aux obtentions végétales
j'ai toujours défendu ce système puisque
je le rappelle par rapport au brevetage
du vivant
si on n'avait pas cette capacité
forfaitaire à financer la recherche
un jour ou l'autre la capacité
d'innovation ne serait plus donné qu'aux
grands industriels etc au grandes
entreprises et là on a un système qui
fonctionne et qui permet de financer la
recherche qui profite à tout le monde
donc sur cette question je défends et je
défendrai toujours ce système de
l'obtention qui me paraît être le plus
adapté aux enjeux pour l'avenir
mais sur la question vous avez posé sur
la question des contrefaçons lié à la
garantie qu'on doit apporter aux
semences de fermes et là dessus on a
travaillé dans le cadre de la ppn sur la
contrefaçon pour expliquer de manière
très claire que les semences de ferme
dans les conditions définies par le code
de la propriété intellectuelle ne
constitue pas une contrefaçon c'est le
premier point
exonérée par voie de conséquence ces
semences de ferme des domaines pour
lesquels des pouvoirs renforcés sont
conférés par ailleurs dans cette loi aux
douanes retenue et destruction puisque
on est quand même dans un débat sur la
contrefaçon dans le projet doit l'avenir
nous avons expliciter le fait que la
présence fortuite accidentelle de
matériel protégées par des droits de
propriété intellectuelle dans des
cultures y compris des semences de fer
ne constitue pas une contrefaçon
et nous avons permis par le régime
fiscal applicable aux échanges de
semences dans le respect de la
réglementation soit celui de l'entr'aide
que vous avez évoqué de faire ces
échanges dans le cadre des jets i2e
groupement d'intérêts économiques et
environnementaux les avancées au delà de
la loi même son que le décret qui
élargit la liste des semences autorisée
en france 2 ferme transmis aujourd'hui
au conseil d'état ajoute je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure un monsieur sénateur très
espèces au 21e qui existe déjà
le plan se mange durable au sein du
projet agro écologie lancée en décembre
2012 vient conforter ses choix
stratégiques le co financement de la
recherche sur le développement des
variétés adaptées
environnement dans lequel des appels
d'offres du projet qu'asda va aussi dans
ce sens et un travail de fond permanent
pour mettre tous les acteurs autour de
la table et aboutir à des solutions
consensuelles et des accords
interprofessionnels sur la rémunération
de la recherche c'est ce qui avait été
évoqué dans la question précédente
donc on est je le dis je le répète dans
une volonté de dépasser des oppositions
de faire en sorte que les semences de
ferme
puisse la voir 3 et c'est un droit qui
est donné aux agriculteurs en même temps
rappelons nous cette chose simple si
nous n'avions pas le financement de la
recherche seules les grandes industries
pourrait financer des innovations et à
ce moment là ça nous coûterait très cher
voilà le schéma clair et net sur cette
question merci mon choix chers collègues
oui merci monsieur le ministre je pense
que ces précisions permettront de
clarifier les choses dans l'esprit de
tout un chacun et nous attendons la
suite des travaux sur ce dans ce domaine
concernant à la fois l'utilisation dé se
met des semences sur les exploitations
et dans le domaine de l'entr'aide ce qui
est une demande légitime de la part d
exploitation merci la parole à michel le
scouarnec pour le groupe crc
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a
quelques semaines la commission des
affaires économiques a voté une
proposition de résolution relative à la
mise sur le marché et la brevetabilité
des semences et obtention végétale
ce texte devenu résolution du sénat le
17 janvier dernier
donc 2014 dans sa version initiale
transmise à la commission des affaires
économiques
la proposition de résolution rappelé
notamment que la priorité devait être
accordée à une protection par le
certificat d'obtention végétale le
coffre et devait limiter les
possibilités de protection par le brevet
lors de l'examen en commission les
sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe crc
ont déposé un amendement afin de
réaffirmer le principe de nombreux
tabilité du vivant en effet nous
souhaitions apporter des garanties pour
protéger la liberté de la recherche de
la production et des échanges dans le
domaine agricole par notre amendement
devenu
né à 18 de la proposition de résolution
nous avons fait inscrire l'attachement
aux caractères nombre de tables des
plantes issues de la sélection génétique
tout particulièrement dans le cas de
plantes obtenues par des procédés
d'amélioration classique et que soient
exclus en conséquence les plantes comme
les variétés du domaine de la
brevetabilité monsieur le ministre
aimerions nous assurer que vous partagez
les recommandations du sénat
comment allez vous garantir que cela
s'applique avec rigueur malgré la
pression des compagnies de
biotechnologies transnationales et les
usa dans le cadre des négociations du
traité transatlantique
porté par le g20 l'initiative pour le
blé est présidé par la france
comment il promouvoir cette position et
enfin comment envisagez-vous de traduire
ce principe essentiel pour les pratiques
agricoles dans les missions
particulières concernant la création
variétale des différents services d'état
et opérateurs publics je vous remercie
très bien merci monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture
ce président est monsieur sénateurs sur
ce sujet qui porte encore une fois sur
le débat sur système d'obtention les
brevetage c'est vrai que la frontière
entre les deux systèmes doit être
précisé et clarifiée j'en suis
parfaitement d'accord et j'ai pourquoi
je voudrais vous indiquer qu'il y a dans
ce domaine des travaux qui sont engagés
pour mieux articuler ces deux
possibilités offertes sur le vin
possibilité ces deux choix qui sont
assez différentes puisque on l'a dit
d'ailleurs l'obtention permet ensuite au
delà
l'utilisation et le développement d'un
certain nombre de souffrances alors que
le brevetage c'est quelque chose qui
rend difficile ce processus ou en tout
cas il faut le payer donc moi j'ai
demandé il ya un rapport une discussion
qui est en cours au niveau du haut
conseil sur la biodiversité qui a été
établie en 2013 réunissant la
confédération paysanne et l'ogc nice
et qui fera l'objet d'un colloque fin
avril que je dois moi même conclure deux
sujets principaux sont en débat veillez
à l'articulation claire du champ du breu
brevets avec celui du coffre et à ce que
le chant du brevet soit clairement
encadrée c'est je crois votre souhait et
veiller à que ce que tous les acteurs du
secteur y compris les agriculteurs qui
utilisent les semences soient clairement
informés des droits de propriété attaché
aux semences qu'ils utilisent cette
diffusion et transparence d'information
fait l'objet du deuxième axe du plan
semences durable pour une information
accessible et complète des utilisateurs
il ya donc un travail approfondi qu est
engagé sur ce sujet au niveau national
je crois aussi qu'il faudra qu'on
langage à l'échelle européenne
car dans ce débat à l'échelle de
l'europe il y à des améliorations et des
progrès des clarifications à apporter
par ailleurs la loi d'avenir dans la loi
d'avenir nous avons soutenu un
amendement qui vise à exclure de la
portée des brevets relatifs à
l'information génétique sur le végétal
toute présence fortuite ou accidentelle
dans une culture
merci alors pour la réplique la parole
et à andy david madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci de votre réponse nous
souhaitions avec michel le scouarnec et
mon groupe attiré particulièrement votre
attention et je crois que vous nous avez
entendu sur les dérives des droits
attachés à la propriété intellectuelle
couplé à l'essor des biotechnologies et
leurs conséquences que vous connaissez
également graves sur les pratiques et la
recherche agricole
vous le savez des contentieux sont en
cours au niveau européen notamment en
raison de la politique menée par
l'office européen des brevets qui ont
mai dernier vous le savez bien octroyé à
syngeta un brevet garantissant à la
firme suisse par exemple des droits
exclusifs sur un poivron issus du
croisement entre un poivron
commercialisés et une variété originaire
de jamaïque connu pour sa capacité à
résister à plusieurs insectes nuisibles
si ce brevet monsieur ministre n'est pas
annulée il empêchera d'autres
sélectionneurs d'utiliser librement
cette variété même s'il ne s'agit là en
aucun cas d'une invention
donc nous sommes satisfaits que vous
nous ayez entendu puisque l'inra à nos
côtés
c'est positionner également contre la
brevetabilité des plantes et des gènes
et leurs chartes de propriété est en
cours de révision j'espère que vous vous
en inspirer monsieur ministre merci la
parole à joël labbé pour le groupe
écologiste
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues et j'en profite pour
saluer tous les gens qui nous regardent
parce qu'il paraît qu'ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux et c'est vraiment bien
qu'ils puissent s'intéresser à nos
débats ma question
ma question s'orientera aujourd'hui sur
les efforts nécessaires de recherche
agronomique portant sur le développement
de variétés de semences et de plants
adapté à des systèmes agri alimentaire
innovants cela en cohérence avec les
nouvelles orientations agroécologiques
inscrite dans la loi d'avenir agricole
la diversité génétique participe à une
meilleure utilisation de la biodiversité
dans les systèmes agricoles
elle permet de réduire les risques de
maladies de stabiliser voire d'augmenter
les rendements et d'améliorer la
résilience des systèmes de production
or la sélection végétale telle qu'elle
est pratiquée aujourd'hui est au service
quasi exclusive du mode de production de
l'agriculture intensive
grande consommatrice d'intrants
chimiques pour accompagner le
développement de nouvelles pratiques
agroécologiques économe et autonome
liées au terroir
il est nécessaire de disposer de
variétés adaptées nombreux sont les
paysans qui attendent un véritable
effort en ce sens de la sélection
professionnelle notamment du service
public dont c'est le rôle
parallèlement des initiatives paysanne
cherche tard développer les variétés
locales parfois adaptés de nouvelles
espèces et à retrouver une autonomie
vis-à-vis de la production de
l'utilisation et de la conservation des
semences
malgré tout l'intérêt qu'elle représente
ses nombreuses expériences de recherche
coopérative et participative qui place
le développement et l'innovation
paysanne au coeur de leurs objectifs ne
bénéficient pas faute de chercheurs
dédiée du soutien suffisant des
organismes de recherche publics en
matière de sélection végétale la
collaboration du monde de la recherche
avec la société civile avec le monde
paysan apparaît pourtant indispensable
tant le potentiel d'innovation est
important
aussi je vous demande monsieur le
ministre quel moyen comptez-vous mettre
en oeuvre pour impliquer davantage nos
organismes de recherche nationaux sur
cette question à l'instar de ce que l'on
voit dans certains pays européens bien
plus avancés que nous dans ce domaine
des roches des recherches sur les
agricultures alternative
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre vous à la parole le président
monsieur le sénateur je l'avais je
voudrais d'abord jusqu'aux origines
petites choses j'ai dit hcb tout à
l'heure au conseil la biodiversité mais
c'est la diversité du sénat qui m'a fait
faire une petite erreur c'est au conseil
aux biotechnologies dont je voudrais
juste corriger et deuxième point je vais
vous dire aussi qu'on va sortir à pour
le salon de l'agriculture un document
sur l'agro écologie ee et 10 points clés
pour comprendre dans lequel il ya la
question des semences et en particulier
le plan se mange durable et la lecture
durable qui va figurer et qui va
mobiliser au travers des orientations
qu'on a évoqué un ce qui j'ai rappelé
tout à l'heure près d'un million 33
millions d'euros
un parent donc on va consacrer à ce plan
cette somme et les thématiques de cet
appel à projets sur ces grandes
questions liées aux blancs semences
agriculture durable porte
essentiellement sur les préoccupations
justement agroécologiques cyr comment on
rentre dans ce processus au travers de
la mobilisation de la recherche et des
semences aussi afin de stimuler la
mobilisation des acteurs de la recherche
publique et privée française sur le
développement de variétés de semences et
de plants adapté à des systèmes
agricoles et alimentaires innovants je
rappelle que la france s'est engagée à
l'échelle mondiale avec la fao sur un
grand colloque sur l'agroécologie dire
que tout ça s'enclenche dans un
processus qui est bien sûr national
européen et international
ainsi l'appel à projets de 2014 qui a
été lancé le 23 décembre 2013 et qui se
clôture le 5 mars 2014 intitulé
développer des variétés et des semences
et des plants adapté à des systèmes agri
alimentaire innovants en réponse au
changement de modèle agricole retiendra
en priorité les projets permettant de
favoriser un renforcement d'orientation
du progrès génétique vers l'est
variétés adaptées à des conduites
culturales diversifiée permettant
notamment de répondre à l'objectif de
réduction des intrants et ça c'est un
objectif économique c'est de
l'innovation
moi ça nous coûtera cher de produire
mieux on pourra être compétitif
c'est dire que l'environnement et les
choix que nous faisons rejoignent les
choix de compétitivité et d' approche
économique
les approches six thèmes seront
privilégiés savez que je suis très
attaché à cette idée de systèmes ainsi
que les projets permettant d'identifier
d'exploiter de et de potentialiser les
interactions positives avec les autres
leviers de ses actions donc voilà un
plan un million 1 l 33 millions d'euros
seront disponibles et ont fixé au petit
ses objectifs à ce plan de semences
durable merci mon cher collègue
j'entends votre réponse volontariste ma
collègue marie blandas présidente de la
de la commission enseignement recherche
me rappelle que les organismes publics
de recherche doivent contribuer aux
recherches participative et s'est
inscrit dans la loi maintenant
par contre je voudrais quand même vous
rappeler que moins de 100 équivalents
temps-plein dédiée à l'agriculture bio
sur plus de 7500 titulaire dans notre
grand service de l'inra donc je crois
qu'il y a à faire vous êtes volontaire
là dessus monsieur le ministre on vous
attend vous avez évoqué les appels
d'offres alors l'immense majorité des
appels à projets de recherche exclut de
fait les associations de paysanne et la
société civile qui ne disposent pas de
moyens financiers et administratives
exigées
elle réserve ses partenariats aux
entreprises privées susceptibles de
bénéficier toujours et ça se comprend
d'un retour sur investissement
issu de droits de propriété
intellectuelle qui interdisent les
pratiques paysans et paysannes
collaborative et je crois qu'il ya lieu
justement de rectifier cela je vous
remercie
merci alors pour la question suivante
monsieur le président raymond vall pour
le groupe rdse
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez répondu
déjà en grande partie à la question
j'avais donc à vous poser est donc je me
réjouis d'abord que vous ayez souligné
le dynamisme remarquable de nos
entreprises de semences et de plants et
bien sûr les chiffres vous avez cité
méritait qu'on les rappelle
et c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi le groupe
rdse avait choisi de soutenir la loi cov
de 2011 considérant qu'elle consolider
un modèle de protection de la propriété
industrielle moins pire que celui du
brevet qui verrouille de façon
dramatique la recherche pour autant le
savoir faire et la volonté patients de
locuteurs ou encore ses choix de
rotation ont en effet contribué à la
conservation in situ des séances à la
préservation et surtout à au
renouvellement de la biodiversité
cultivée à nos yeux et vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure il fallait et en
autorisation de la d 21 espèces
recensées à l'échelon européen
vous avez souligné que votre projet
prévoyait d'en rajouter 13 et au minimum
exonérés de la contribution volontaire
obligations l'obligatoire des cultures
utilisant des semences de ferme à des
fins d'autoconsommation pour des
cultures réalisées en application une
obligation environnementale des avancées
semblent se dessiner dans votre projet
de loi et nous serons évidemment revenir
ce sujet vous l'avez rappelé nous savons
aussi qu'il faudra nourrir 9 milliards
d'humains en 2050
il ya donc à notre avis une place pour
des modèles culturaux et culturels
divers nous devons reconnaître droit
fondamental série culte heures et être
inventeur de leur choix agronomique et
leur laisser être les inventeurs nous
devons pour autant privilégier une
logique de complémentarité sur une
logique de défiance et d'accompagnement
monsieur le ministre nous souhaitons
avoir de votre part une confirmation
pour assurer des cultures sur les moyens
que vous comptez mettre en oeuvre pour
sauvegarder l'utilisation des semences
de terre merci très bien monsieur le
ministre
son président le sénateur
oui j'ai déjà dans les cadres des
réponses précédentes apporter un certain
nombre de pistes et de réponse à la
question qui posait mais je veux
rappeler que dans le domaine des
semences sur ce qui est collecté au
travers dé sauver aujourd'hui 15% est
destiné à la recherche
si un secteur aujourd'hui qui investit
dans la recherche
le domaine défense français est un
domaine dans lequel
il existe cette recherche c'est cette
recherche publics collectifs et donc je
pense que ça il faut le souligner c'est
l'occasion de rajouter des éléments à ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
alors après il ya les débats sur ce
qu'ont été évoqué tout à l'heure les
choix on doit favoriser la diversité
on doit pas se focaliser uniquement sur
quelques choix parce que je pense que
c'est très important je le sais pour
lorsque je me déplace à l'étranger
la qualité des semences française est
extrêmement demandés et là l'expérience
et d' expertise française de la même
manière c'est la recherche et des
entreprises
dernier débat en date que nous avons eu
en début de semaine avec nos amis
marocains débat avec l'ensemble des
professionnels sur cette question là
encore a été vantée de manière très
claire la collaboration que nous avons
engagées avec le maroc qui permet de
développer des semences adaptées à des
climats spécifiques
donc on est bien là dans un projet
d'organisation ou l'innovation et la
recherche sont partie prenante des
enjeux que l'on doit défendre en ayant
cette ouverture à l'ensemble des modèles
possible en préservant ça a été dit la
possibilité des semences à la ferme
mais tout ça ça fait un ensemble qui a
une efficacité économique écologique et
social qui me paraît très important très
important on est je le rappelle le
premier exportateur mondial donc ce
modèle qui fonctionne faut-il qu'on soit
capable d'alimenter les enjeux et les
réponses aux besoins de demain
c'est tout le débat que nous avons j'y
rajoute bien sûr ce que j'ai dit sur le
casse d'art avec le plan sur les
semences durable un plus d'un million
d'euros qui sera mobilisée là encore
pour favoriser cette recherche mais je
le rappelle dans ce secteur 15 % de ce
qui est collecté est réinvesti dans la
recherche c'est quand même à souligner
et à appuyer
merci monsieur président val si vous
souhaitez réagir
merci monsieur produire non je voudrais
simplement dire à monsieur le ministre
que je suis satisfait par sa réponse
ainsi comment groupe et que je voudrais
saluer son courage voilà persie très
bien je vous remercie je passe la parole
à rémy pointereau pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est vrai que les questions sont assez
étroites dans un sujet
l'asec circonscrit nous avons bien
compris monsieur miss à travers vos
diverses interventions que votre
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à la
brevetabilité des jeunes natifs jeunes
natifs c'est à dire la découverte d'un
gène à l'intérieur d'une espèce
c'est également depuis 2011
la position des semenciers français dans
le cadre des ses mauvais et le sénat et
le lieu nous avons dès l'origine poser
des questions quant à la brevetabilité
des inventions biotechnologiques
introduite dans les variétés végétales
nous avons ainsi fait introduire à
l'exception de sélection dans le cadre
de la transcription de la directive 98
44 sur les inventions biotechnologiques
qui est également reprise dans le cadre
du brevet unitaire européen par le
précédent gouvernement et heureusement
par le gouvernement actuel
mais il reste un problème permanent sur
les jeunes natifs et des positions
concernant le brevet sur ces mêmes
jeunes
ainsi un acteur qui intégrerait un gènes
brevetés dans sa variété serait dans
l'obligation de s'entendre avec le
propriétaire du brevet pour en faire
l'exploitation commerciale ce qui serait
vous vous en doutez très difficile
derrière les déclarations de principe
monsieur ministre qu allez vous engager
comme démarche pour introduire dans la
loi française et la réglementation
européenne
la non brevetabilité des jeunes natifs
je vous remercie de votre question de
votre réponse stéphane le foll
monsieur le président le sénateur lampre
sujet alors extrêmement précis sur les
jeunes natifs
quoi le sénat un travail qui ici
montrent toute l'acuité et l' expertise
qui existe dans cette noble assemblée
donc sur cette question des jeunes
natifs d'abord il ya un premier point
qu'il faut pour être simple sur lequel
il faut qu'on réponde c'est que sur
cette question il ya une discussion à
l'échelle européenne sur toute la
question des semences qui est engagé et
c'est vrai qu'on ne pourra pas avoir de
législation purement national sur cette
question
ceci étant dit ce que vous venez de dire
par rapport aux jeunes natifs est
parfaitement vrai d'abord mais ça c'est
pas le sujet mais les questions que ça
pose par rapport à l'utilisation
possible après de ses brevets est une
vraie une vraie difficulté
donc je les ai dit tout à l'heure dans
le cadre de ce qui a été engagé dans le
cadre du hcb est dans ce que nous allons
avoir à faire d'ici avril dans ce
colloque qu'on va organiser qui a permis
de réunir le cnjs et un certain nombre
d'autres partenaires et en particulier
la confédération paysanne pour tout
choix clair on va avoir à tirer des
conclusions des travaux qui sont engagés
et sur cette question là en particulier
mais je rappelle que ça doit être du
niveau national une démarche
d'anticipation une démarche sur laquelle
il faut qu'on essaye de calais
l'articulation brevet c o v et qu'on le
fasse
nous avec une vraie réflexion
approfondie pour pouvoir porter le
message à l'échelle européenne parce
qu'il faudra qu'on traite cette question
à l'échelle européenne puisque c'est
dans le cadre de la législation
européenne que sur ces problèmes de
brevetage en particulier sur les jeunes
natifs
on doit trouver une solution qui va être
de faire une vraie différence et qui
évite ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
c'est qu'on aille chercher un gène dans
une dans un végétal dans un endroit du
monde qui n'a pas été d'ailleurs ni
craignent innover par tel ou tel qui
peut être récupéré
intégré dans une autre plante est
considéré ensuite avec un brevet déposé
comme étant la propriété de celui qu'il
a fait ça c'est quand même un vrai sujet
un vrai sujet qui doit être traité
nous nous allons traiter nous allons en
discuter puis après il faudra qu'on soit
suffisamment fort ça pourra faire
l'objet d'ailleurs d'un débat ou de
position plus forte qu'ils soient prises
pour qu'à l'échelle européenne on pèse
pour que ça ne puisse pas avoir les
conséquences que vous évoquiez tout de
suite le sénateur
merci monsieur le sénateur merci
messieurs mise de constater que le sénat
est une chambre d'experts mais saviez
vous saviez également que le certificat
d'obtention végétale dont j'étais le
rapporteur est finalement une bonne
boîte à outils pour protéger la
recherche en création variétale et parce
que ça permet l'accès totalement libre à
ces variétés
ainsi n'importe qui peut créer de
nouvelles variétés à partir de variété
déjà commercialisée et tout le monde et
est ainsi à égalité de traitement
contrairement aux brevets qui bloque
l'accès variétés pour en créer de
nouvelles et qui n'est adapté je dirais
que pour les ogm puisque là il s'agit
vraiment d'invention on ajoute un gène
concernant la résistance à un herbicide
ou un insecticide c'est complètement
différent
pour autant il faut que les chercheurs
les sélectionneurs les agriculteurs joue
gagnant gagnant et c'est pour ça il faut
favoriser la recherche parce que on n'a
pas besoin de produire de plus en plus
pour nourrir la planète mais il faut que
chacun puisse je dirais 1-1 une juste
rémunération et le système de protection
de l' obtention végétale encourage
davantage la recherche variétale que le
brevet je crois que c'est un moyen de
protéger sans confisqués merci alors la
parole est à présent un richard yong
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
porte sur le projet de règlement sur
l'enregistrement des obtentions
végétales qui a été proposée par la
commission européenne au mois de février
2013 le ce projet vise à rassembler en
un règlement c'est à dire d'application
immédiate
une quinzaine de directive différentes
c'est vrai que c'est assez confus assez
compliquée à appliquer donc
l'idée même est bonne donc c'est une
idée de rassembler ses textes en un
texte unique et deux au fond prolongé
l'amélioration de l'enregistrement des
variétés de la certification des
semences
il propose également d'allonger la durée
de protection de 10 à 30 ans 30 ans qui
est considérable et enfin il couvre un
certain nombre de choses comme les
semences de niche
les variétés anciennes qui sont tombées
en désuétude et un certain nombre
d'autres points
c'est un texte important puisque comme
ça a été dit nous sommes un des
principaux pays actif en matière de
production et d'exportation de semences
le sénat avait pris position sur ces
questions en faisant part de réticences
d'une part sur le nombre d'actes
délégués sur le fait qu'au fond c'était
la commission qui prenait en main
l'ensemble du domaine sur la durée nous
trouvions que trente ans c'était une
durée trop longue et enfin sur le fait
que tout ce qui était forestiers étaient
inclus alors que sarah relève d'autres
d'autres modes de production donc ma
question monsieur le ministre c'est
devant le fait d'ailleurs que le
parlement européen est très réticent
quelle est la position du gouvernement
français et comment voyez vous l'avenir
de ce texte très bien la parole à
monsieur le ministre stéphane le foll de
prison mais ce sénateur d'abord sur
cette question vous l'avez évoqué il ya
une proposition qui a été mis sur la
table par la commission sur un nouveau
règlement sur une évolution du règlement
européen qui ne sera pas l'aboutissement
du débat sur la question globale
obtention brevetage sur le cadre
juridique général mais qui fait partie
du débat ce que vous avez dit monsieur
le sénateur c'est que est la question
que vous me posez c'est quelle est la
position du gouvernement par rapport à
la proposition du de la commission qui
je le sais je crois que c'est hier soir
a vu la commission de la vie culte
du parlement européen refusé la
proposition de règlement de la
commission
bon un mois et le gouvernement français
sommes favorables à l'idée d'une
simplification il ya trop de règlements
et il faut qu'on soit capable de
simplifier et de moderniser ses
règlements donc là dessus on doit
trouver un point d'accord ensemble les
évolutions proposées qui sont cohérentes
avec la politique nationale du placement
durables en particulier l'intégration de
la dimension environnementale dans les
critères d'examen de la performance des
variétés en vue de leur mise en marché
par définition nous y sommes aussi
favorables mais vous l'avez dit vous
avez posé d'ailleurs 2-2 question dans
ce qui a été la position du sénat il ya
derrière ce règlement les actes délégués
qui donne une position extrêmement
favorable à la commission et si j'en
juge par ce qui vient de se passer sur
l'autorisation du maïs punir 15 107
cette semaine alors que le parlement
européen à une large majorité a voté
contre l'autorisation que 19 pays sur
vingt-sept se sont prononcés contre
l'autorisation et que 4 et pas des
moindres pays se sont abstenus la
commission a dit que l'appliquer et
qu'elle mettait l'autorisation renvoyant
aux états la responsabilité de décider
ensuite je suis comme vous extrêmement
vigilants et prudents par rapport à ce
règlement sur l'espace donné dans le
cadre des actes délégués à la commission
ensuite pour l'appliquer donc si on est
d'accord sur deux objectifs me
moderniser simplifiée intégrer la
dimension environnementale
là dessus on peut soutenir il faut qu'on
soit extrêmement vigilants aux
conditions ok ça s'appliquera ensuite en
particulier à cause des actes délégués
pour la commission de réduisons aussi
ses possibilités merci un chariot oui
merci monsieur mais les choix que nous
partageons ce sentiment je pense que sur
le fond la commission a été
trop timide et n'a pas affirmé
suffisamment fort la primauté du
certificat d'obtention végétale dans le
système européen par rapport aux états
unis qui utilisent et enfin pas
essentiellement uniquement le brevet
ayant en fait un combat et ça sera dans
le débat transatlantiques entre l'europe
et les états unis entre le seo v et le
breton et j'attire l'attention de des
collègues que la grande chambre de
recours de l'office européen des brevets
doit rendre une décision dans les mois
qui viennent sur le fond concernant le
brocoli et concernant la tomate qui sera
une décision qui fondera la suite delà
de la politique de séparation entre le
brevet et le seo vais donc on voit bien
que c'est pas au niveau français comme
la dyle excellemment le ministre mais
que c'est au niveau européen que ça se
passe merci merci la parole à madame
sophie primas pour le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je souhaite attirer
votre attention sur les moyens
juridiques donnée à la lutte contre la
contrefaçon de produits phytosanitaires
donc on s'éloigne un petit peu des
semences les importations parallèles et
les fraudes aux pesticides sont de
véritables fléaux qui occasionne la
diffusion de substances actives non
autorisées sur notre territoire
celles ci peuvent mettre gravement en ce
péril la santé des utilisateurs avoir
des effets naturellement dramatiques sur
l'environnement et l'alimentation et
constitue également un préjudice pour
les entreprises dans le cadre de la
mission d'information sur les femmes
nous interrompons en cette séance de
questions cribles pour prendre tout de
suite la direction de sciences po paris
éditions spéciales sur les chaînes
parlementaires pour suivre en direct le
grand oral des candidats à la mairie de
paris
devant les étudiants de sciences po les
cinq candidats qui s'exprimeront à tour
de rôle pendant